So for a given function, we've learned that the domain of that function, is the
set of all allowable inputs, the set of all of the values of the independent
variable that we can plug into our function to come up with a value. But if we
were to talk about the allowable input so much, it's also probably important for
us to learn about the possible outputs, the values that the function can equal.
The set of all possible outputs of a function is called its range. And how might
you find the range? Well, we can figure out what the range is by plugging in all
the different values of the independent variable that are in the domain. Once
we've covered all of those, we will have covered all of the values in the range.
So, the domain then is associated with the independent variable, like x in this
case and in many other cases. And the range is associated with dependent
variables like f of x. For each of these different variables, the domain and the
range basically state what values the corresponding variables can take on. So,
considering this definition of the range, what do you think the range of this
function is? Remember, this is just the set of all the different values for the
function, all the different vertical coordinates expand in this graph itself.